here that starts off well it looks like
it has nothing to do with integration to
begin with so it says show that 4x plus
22 on X plus 6 times X plus 4 equals
them in you've got a pair of fractions
on the right-hand side so when you're
asked to show a result what you need to
do is to start with one side the left or
the right and then work with it simplify
manipulate adjust it so that it looks
like the other side but then you cannot
do is show you know start from this line
here and then just start manipulating
right because the reason why that
doesn't work is suppose you start with
two things that happen to be equal like
for equals you know two times two
suppose we were asked to prove this okay
well if four equals two times two is my
first line of working what am i do is I
might say oh well you know let's let's
subtract 4 from both sides that's 2
times 2 take away 4 4 times 4 1 minus 4
on the left is our that's 0 this is 4
minus 4 that's also 0 and I'm like oh 0
equals 0
that's great but it doesn't actually
prove anything
this doesn't constitute a proof what
you've got to do is start with one side
and move to the other so let's get rid
of all of this when I have a look at
this for me and most people's brains
tends to go from complicated and messy
too simple and we've been training you
for years to simplify algebraic
expressions so when I look at this which
side looks simpler the left-hand side
looks simpler so I'm gonna make that my
endpoint the right-hand side looks
Messier so I'm gonna start with that I'm
gonna write right-hand side RHS equals
I'm just going to quote it 2 over X plus
4 plus 2x plus 10 all divided by x
squared plus 10x plus 24 now when you're
proving one of these things I know I
want to end up at the left hand side so
I keep one eye on the algebra I'm
manipulating and then I keep my other
eye on my destination as it were to make
sure I'm getting closer at every step
now I notice that the left hand side is
a single fraction and the bottom there
has been factorized so what that
suggests to me is that the two fractions
I've just written on the
right-hand-side need to be number one
factorized and number two combined into
one fraction so let's have a go at that
there's not much to factorize with this
left-hand fraction so I'm just gonna
leave it for a brief moment on the
right-hand side here I've got 2x plus 10
and then on the denominator I've got
this quadratic expression x squared plus
10x plus 24 so I've want to factorize
this I'm searching for a pair of numbers
they add to 10 they multiply to 24 and
you've got a big hint in the original
question I am thinking that it's highly
likely I'll end up with X plus 6 times X
plus 4 and sure enough if you go ahead
and check the numbers that is indeed
what again so now I've got the
factorizing down that's good what's left
is to combine these two fractions into
one so in order to do that I need a
common denominator because I've already
got this common factor of x plus 4 all I
need to do is multiply the left-hand
fraction by X plus 6 on X plus 6 so if I
do that on the top there's the numerator
here's the denominator X plus 6 X plus 4
this fraction here hasn't changed so I'm
going to cheat a tiny bit so this is
faster for you to watch and now I have
the same denominator on both fractions
so I can combine these two together I've
got two lots of X plus 6 I've got a 2x
plus 10 and then all of that is divided
by this new denominator that I've just
found X plus 6 X plus 4 we're almost
there
on the numerator again looking back at
where I need to end up on the numerator
I just want to expand and collect like
terms so it seems to me I'm going to get
2x plus 12 plus 2x plus 10 that bit
hasn't changed so this is looking
promising I'm dividing by X plus 6 X
plus 4 and now I'm pretty much their
entire you can see the 2 X plus 2 X
gives you 4x the 12 plus 10 gives you 22
everything is divided by the denominator
which hasn't changed for a few lines now
and that's what I was required to find
so I complete my proof by saying as
required
okay so that question didn't seem like
it had much to do with calculus and it
didn't until you get to part two the
last question says hence find the
integral law and then you get this
expression in here now you need to pay
close attention to this word hence
occasionally you'll see the word hence
or sometimes a variation on this is
hence or otherwise you'll see this in a
question which means something very
specific about how you're expected to
solve the question when you see
hence what that means is the thing you
just show that result that came from the
earlier part you need to use that when
you see the phrase or otherwise what
they're essentially saying is well if
you've got some other wonderful way to
solve this problem then go for it
but otherwise we're trying to give you a
nudge in the right direction this
question here part two just says hence
that means it doesn't give you an option
you absolutely must use part one in
order to solve part two thankfully this
makes it dramatically easier so how do
we use part one to solve part two the
thing that I noticed if you look at
these two parts together is that 4x plus
22 over X plus 6 times X plus 4 this
thing we're being asked to integrate in
here it is equivalent to or it's exactly
identical to the left hand side of the
equation that we were working with in
part one so part two is asking us to
integrate something that appeared in
part one now if they're asking us in
part one to show these two things are
equal and then they say in part two hey
integrate this thing
well that means integrating this is the
same as integrating this you can
integrate either of them if they are
indeed the same function so that's what
I'm going to do I'm going to say this is
equal to the integral of and instead of
writing the left-hand side of the
equation I'm going to write the
right-hand side of the equation so that
is 2 over X plus 4 and then I am adding
what have I got here
2x Plus 10 we use track of myself 2x
plus 10 divided by x squared plus 10x
plus 24 and all of that I'm integrating
with respect to
X now how does this help at all like
it's got more stuff in it if anything
it's Messier its Messier but it's
Messier in a way that's helpful because
even though this is much longer than the
you know thing that's being asked to
integrate in part to because it's longer
precisely because longer I can tackle
each part individually so let's have a
look at the first expression two over X
plus four
what's this equal to when I integrate
it's going to be two natural log of X
plus four and again I've got those
absolute value signs there then when I
have a look at the next one 2x plus 10
look carefully at that 2x plus 10 is not
a coincidence do you notice the 2x is
just above an x squared and this 10 is
just above the 10 X you've got an F - on
F situation here right so therefore the
integral of this is just log of whatever
the denominator was which in this case
is x squared plus 10x plus 24 and then
of course I add my constant of
integration so the whole point of part
one was actually to write the integral
in a way that we could deal with in part
two and this I think is you know done
but if you want to simplify this even
further you could use one of the log
laws that we've seen earlier on in the
paper by taking this right-hand log
which is log of x squared or x squared
plus 20x plus 24 which I'm already
written I can write that as log of X
plus 4x plus 6 so this guy on the right
hand side I can actually break into two
different functions so it's 2 log X plus
4 plus log of X plus 4 + log X plus 6
plus my constant you can see here what
I've created is some actual like terms
I've got a single log of X plus 4 here
and then I've got two of them over on
the left so that leaves me with 3 log of
absolute value x plus 4 plus log
absolute value of x plus 6 plus my
constant of integration
and you're finally done there it is
worth saying you know by the by this
point here you have done the integration
and all this stuff underneath is just
making it nice and neat